plus de deux mois après l annonce de la
fermeture de l'usiné de pneus
bridgestone à béthune les salariés
maintiennent la pression à l'appel de
l'intersyndicale ils sont nombreux à se
rassembler depuis tôt ce matin devant
les grilles de l'usiné géant japonais
avait brutalement annoncé mi septembre
la fermeture courant en 2021 du site qui
emploie depuis cent soixante trois
personnes le gouvernement ensuite
proposé un plan de sauvetage avec le
maintien de plus de 550 emplois
tentative rejetée par l'industriel mi
novembre
c'est la première fois que le conflit
porte à l'extérieur de l'usiné
pour en parler nous retrouvons sur place
notre envoyée spéciale estelle marché et
c'est le bonjour alors dans quel état
d'esprit sont les employés de
bridgestone ce matin eh bien écoutez
d'o'reilly du dégoût de la tristesse de
l'inquiétude aussi vous l'avez dit c'est
une journée d'action pour dénoncer la
décision du groupe japonais japonais 1
qui détient à cette cuisine de la ferme
et alors vous allez le voir en ce moment
1 sur ces images de bâtisses gosselin
c'est anticiper éloigné des grilles de
leasing puisque les salariés ont procédé
à une action symbolique vous le voyez
ils sont munis à de croix en bois des
croix en bois qu'ils vont aller planter
sur un rond-point à quelques mètres de
là pour symboliser bien la mort un de
leurs usines cette cuisine vous l'avais
dit à l'emploi à 8 163 salariés elle
existe depuis 1961 c'est la plus grosse
usine de la région béthunoise alors vous
vous en doutez je voulais dit il ya du
dégoût de l'inquiétude c'est un peu
comme un monument ici certains salariés
on a passé de nombreuses années c'est le
cas de pascal et daniel à qui nous avons
parlé respectivement 24 et 39 ans de
maison
ce qu'ils espèrent obtenir et bien c'est
un peu de reconnaissance de la part de
leur direction je propose de les écouter
c'est pour faire voir que les gens ils
sont pas d'accord de ce qui se passe
surtout comment ça tu es annoncé eux
moi j'étais en repos donc j'ai reçu sa
part un coup de téléphone en me disant
que
ils vont fermer les usines qu on a tous
été surpris on pensait que
éventuellement on peut faire une
saturation mettre des gens en pré
retraite ou structurel usine coopéra à
faire des départs volontaires mais non
c'était carrément comme au succès du
jour en a terminé et béthune ont fermé
au volant mais là le souci c'est que là
les négociations se passent très mal
notre président directeur général de
l'usiné il veut pas lâcher ne pas faire
le veut pas donner l'équivalent de ce
que les gens ont pu produire dans cette
cuisine on est mécontent de ce qui c'est
ce qui arrive maintenant on fait
confiance à l'intersyndicale et qu'on
essaie d'avoir le mieux qui peut nous
accompagner
tu peux nous arriver puisque de toute
façon que vous avez dit clairement
s'arrêter voilà on a plus on n'a pris
aucune
le seul moyen de pression qu'on a c'est
ça c'est de montrer qu'on est lent et
que cela sera pas faire plus rares voilà
pour les revendications doha ce
rassemblement il devrait se poursuivre
une bonne partie de la journée noter que
certains élus locaux sont venus soutenir
les salariés c'est le canada dry à
quatre mains ce qui a pris à la parole
par exemple il ya une dizaine de minutes
un petit peu plus tôt ce matin c'est
xavier bertrand le président de la
région haute france qui est lui venu
aussi apporté son soutien aux salariés
merci beaucoup et c'est el farj pour
toutes ces précisions